shift to the Booker you want to keep
going no no no please please I would
much rather talk about this book
alright so it's called blueprint the
evolutionary origins of a good society
so let's start with the tag there so we
actually live in a good society I can't
believe it I thought we live in the
worst society and I thought capitalism
is evil and the patriarchy had so many
terrible things and we've done horrible
things but you say this is good yeah I'm
appalled can you please explain this yes
yes statement yes okay so I think there
has been a long tradition in the
sciences and in the public domain as
well of focusing on the bad side of
human nature on our propensity for
tribalism or selfishness or violence or
hatred but equally we are natural
selection our evolution has equipped us
and shaped us for love and friendship
and cooperation and teaching and all
these other wonderful qualities and in
fact I would argue that these good
qualities and their benefits must
necessarily have outweighed the bad
qualities and their costs because if I
came near you I'm now speaking over
evolutionary time over tens or hundreds
of thousands of years if I came near you
and you killed me or filled me with lies
or otherwise injured me I would be
better off living separately so so the
so the fact that we live socially
suggests that on balance the benefits of
a connected life must outweigh the costs
so the books the book that what I'm
trying to do is I'm trying to push back
at these claims that we are that humans
are inexorably evil and these arguments
I should make I should say are
supplementary to the body of ideas that
Steven Pinker and others have been
advancing about the sweep of history so
where Steven is interested in historical
forces
I'm interested in the books over there
so yeah and Amy's I see in a bunch of
other the other Steven anyway all my
friends I gotta say you want to be a man
yes please put me over there with those
guys
yes exactly you like some of those guys
yes and schirmer's book I can see yeah
these are great okay so uh yeah the
moral arc that okay great so I'll make
sure you have a copy Oh keep it anyway
so so um so so Stephen is arguing that
you know basically since the the
Enlightenment with the philosophical
principles and the scientific describe
discoveries of the Enlightenment the
world is been getting better and he's a
unquestionably bright we are safer less
violent healthier live longer wealthier
better off in every every possible
dimension and that is largely a product
of historical forces but what I'm
arguing and technological forces but
what I'm arguing that we don't just have
to look to our history to find this
goodness
we can look to our prehistory and
actually over tens of thousands of years
we've been shaped to be good we have
been shaped to be able to live together
in productive ways in in in in good ways
actually in morally good ways I even
argue so so the both works
synergistically these two forces and in
and in fact I would even argue that
these historical and technological
forces are actually just a thin veneer
on top of much more powerful forces so
is there a bizarre evolutionary force
that that inclines us to focus on the
negative oh no that's a good question I
suspect if I had did I get one per show
no no I would say right because if you
had person are things good or bad people
generally tend to bed we watch local
news that is all terrible news yes we're
conditioned sort of so there must be
something that's leading to that yes I
think that I think I know this has been
studied I'm trying to quickly call the
literature to my mind if I had to
speculate on what the conclusions of
that literature would be it would be
that there's more advantage to paying
attention to bad news and good news that
that the fitness advantages survival
advantage the advantage to your well
being from noting a fire in your
vicinity or a predator or a killer
is more advantageous to you than then
the noted the noting the on average the
presence of water or a food or a kindly
person so I think I think that
that's probably why we're hardwired to
be pessimistic but actually we're not
let me be clear so so we we have both
pessimistic and optimistic inclinations
people and of course there's inter
individual variation people vary in this
these personality traits but I think on
overall we are definitely inclined to
the good so when you describe yourself
as an optimist before if you had to try
to parse that out between what you think
human nature is versus upbringing and
everything else could you give it some
percentages I mean were your parents
optimists so that then push to you or I
think it's important not to conflate
personality traits which I am optimist I
think a person by personality with sort
of how to put this exactly the kind of
characteristics of our species so I
think we for example we're a cooperative
species we we cooperate with strangers
which is very unusual other animals will
cooperate with kin but we also cooperate
with non kin this is rare in the animal
kingdom
so I don't know how you would describe
that I wouldn't call that optimism
exactly I would call that something good
opportunity that's a characteristic of
our species and then above and beyond
that we also have personalities with
some of us are optimistic some of us or
not but all of us for example love our
mates so here's an interesting idea why
why do we do that did other animals have
sex with each other we're not the only
animals that do this but we also love
each other we form sentimental
attachments to the people we're having
sex with we are also tend to be
monogamous now we can be bi monogamous I
don't mean social monogamy or even
heterosexual monogamy I mean we form a
long-term attachment to the person we're
having sex with whether it's polygynous
polyandrous straight or gay doesn't
matter we love the person we're with why
why do we have all this capacity well I
talked a little bit about that yeah why
do that and it's universal everywhere in
the world you go no matter what the
marital system people love their
partners it's at least unless we get too
proud of ourselves Birds 90% of bird
species are also monogamous but anyway
so the point is is that there are all
these qualities we have or we befriend
each other why do we do that we we don't
just reproduce with each other we for
long-term non-reproductive unions with
other members of our species namely we
have friends this is very rare in the
animal kingdom we do it certain primates
do it
whales orcas and dolphins do it and
elephants do it why well there's a
reason we do it and it's a wonderful
quality of our species so do you think
societies should be organized to help
these institutions I mean this is where
I could throw out Jordan Peterson's
enforced monogamy yes and you know
people had a field day with that and all
he really was saying was that societies
should kind of look at marriage as an
innocent thing because it's a
foundational thing that will help you
build a family that'll help you build a
full life do you agree that that's part
of what would lead to a good society or
what should be instilled well Isis I
talked about that in the book what I
talked about is that we should be very
wary of efforts to engineer society and
opposition to our evolved proclivities
so societies that try for example to
prevent loving attachments I talked
about communes for example communes have
a problem because in a commune they want
you to feel loyalty to the group to the
commune so therefore feeling a love for
your partner is a threat so many
communes have gone to opposite extremes
both of which are attempting to solve
the same problem so on the one hand you
have the shakers who say no sex no
loving attachment on the other hand you
have communes that say polyamory
everyone loves everybody or can have sex
with everyone both of those are
attempting to sever an individualistic
connection between two people which
therefore you and the same thing happens
in eastern Germany where they try to
sever connections with friends right you
don't you my friends could be spying on
your ratting me out to the Stasi it's
worth sitting there for a sec cause it's
a fascinating idea it's the same force
at work whether you have say two people
don't have any religious he's actually
the same force as have relations yes
with everybody I mean that's that's not
something that the average person is
thinking about but if you're just having
relations and everybody yes you're
actually I don't think they don't
special nobody that's right so they're
both both of those extreme strategies
are tackling the same problem which is
the threat to the collectivity of
individual relationships whether it's
with your partner your sexual partner or
as those about same with your friends or
others so collectivist societies will
often everywhere every
call you comrade so everyone is your
friend same as having polyamory right
it's like the polyamorous equivalent to
everyone dresses the same we all call
each other friend no individual identity
it's a kind of it's a kind of science
fiction dystopia actually so the
argument I make is is that we should be
very wary of efforts to engineer society
and opposition to our interests they're
bound to fail is my argument now there
are brief moments of time and certain
cultures where you can apply a
tremendous cultural force and suppress
some of these innate tendencies so for
example that I talked about the NA so if
you look at societies around the world
that the the the expression of love for
your partner's seen universally accepted
one exception which is the not people in
the Himalayas who have organized society
around brief sexual encounters you're
not supposed to love your partner and so
this is a matrilineal society the women
stay at home the men will go out at
night basically cruising for dates so
they'll be like and it's not uncommon
for every woman to have had sex with
every man in the village and the men
will be knocking on the door take meat
and I take me and she'll pick this guy
tonight and they'll have a brief fling
maybe he can come back and at any moment
either of them can break off the
relationship but even in it and so
there's a whole complex cultural edifice
Marco Polo describes this when he gets
to China the the the Chinese government
thought it was sapping productivity that
everyone was having sex all the time
they were they were saying and we need
to stop this they tried to stamp it out
but it still has existed this this
culture this this cultural set of rules
but even in this society there are
people who want the forbidden fruit of
having a committed relationship and who
flee for because they want to be with
each other forsaking all others so even
this society cannot fully suppress this
desire for love and I look also at
friendship and show that there are some
societies very few which seemed to have
no experience of this notion of
friendship but those societies are
extremely rare and also have certain
idiosyncrasies so with the simple way of
saying that be that there's basically an
evolutionary force that no matter how
far you go to one extreme it has to sort
of push you yes or that it's extremely
difficult
to entirely suppress you can through
force of arms you know you can slaughter
populations you can you can you know you
can you can have very elaborate sort of
autocratic governments you you can have
procedures or other highly evolved
stylized cultures that have gotten to
this for example there's a play as
universal in children and there's one
society the beaming people who really
think play is awful and really try to
suppress the innate tendency of children
to play so there's very little play
among children in that society but it's
these societies are rare and they
require very large cultural forces to
suppress these innate tendencies you
know I was thinking as we've been
talking about this that there's
something also sort of related to our
political situation right now about this
that it seems like we're sort of going
off the deep end
I would sad the argue more on the left
at the moment but I guess if I'm an
optimist here and I describe myself as a
world-weary optimist okay that you're
saying at some point and and whether
Jonathan eight says it's two years down
the road or whatever it is but at some
point it will eventually have to rebound
right yes because sure because what is
it if it doesn't rebound then then
that's just no I don't think Jordan
Peterson would say is just chaos right
yeah I think I think but I I mean I
can't I I think we're in for another I
think it'll be about five or ten years
our society is gonna go through a long
period of of acrimony no I have to say
I'm not you know sir I don't have a wig
each view of history like Oh in the
olden days you know everything was great
I mean let's not forget we had we had
colonialism we had slavery we had we had
anti-immigrant sentiment forever and
ours even though vote I mean yes women
couldn't vote exactly we deemed to have
gay rights you know so so there's always
been this this incredible disconnect
between our wonderful principles in our
society all men are created equal you
know the Bill of Rights can bring tears
to your eyes if you read it as but and
the fact that we didn't out but we are I
think getting better this is the
progressive in me you know the society
we're getting better and better we are
expanding the franchise to more and more
people we are opening up our democracy
we are we are extending rights we are
extending liberties now of course
turn you'll see the government doesn't
grant liberties we are protecting
liberties are you know we are trying to
stay out of it yes exactly and I agree
with that actually I don't think the
liberties serve the government's to
grant but anyway so uh but I think our
society isn't getting better in these
regards I don't think you can you could
say otherwise so I think that we we will
get there it just gonna take some time
so how do you navigate through a messy
time like this if you're someone that's
just kind of awake to these ideas and
you want to be able to express your
individuality but there is a mob or an
amorphous machine that is silencing
things or as you just said before that
you don't want a society that's gonna
push down things that were sort of
always accepted for a long time I'm
slightly paraphrasing but so right now
it's like if you call a man a man
they'll tell you you're a transformer
these these basic things that seem now
we hear about them constantly as if as
if this is just the most important thing
happening no I think there are other
this is the other thing I think that I
think there's certain segments of
Twitter and certain segments of our
society that have made these particular
topics and others very central and
everyone you know the people who want to
or concern about climate change for
people who can I am there people are
concerned about the private Prentis
prison industry as I am these are two
hot topics at Harvard right now so there
was a heckler situation where the
president of Harvard was was not allowed
to speak about he was at an educational
conference and these groups that were
opposed to private ownership of prisons
which I am and concern about climate
change which I also AM they shut the
president now which is ridiculous you
know why did they shut him because they
thought he wasn't taking paying enough
attention to their concern so you you
have this kind of ruled by minorities
right where a minority can hijack the
conversation about whatever particular
topic
they have so everyone's entitled to have
their topics of interest but that
doesn't mean you have to go along with
it right you can have your own ideas
about the topic or you can switch
conversation like I'm not interested in
talking about trans rights today today
I'd like to talk about how motor vehicle
accidents are the one of the leading
killers or the opioid crisis is another
important dilemma or the guns you know
we we we have we have more people are
killed by guns in our society per capita
than any society in the world almost
it's craziness so
so all of these are different people of
different anyway the point I'm making is
that you know if you wish to engage in a
conversation with someone about a topic
they feel strongly about I think it's
incumbent on you to listen to their
arguments think and then respond so do
you think there's an evolutionary reason
that people either basically become sort
of government people or freedom people
so the way you were laying out that
argument a second ago it's like you were
telling me your progressive sir Fred
which I have to do at the time but then
you basically said yeah but all these
things can be accomplished by
libertarianism if you don't believe that
it's the government job to give these
things so that basically it sort of
shows why the the progressives are the
ones screaming on campus all the time
and in in larger society because they
think the system can be perfected to get
it however they want where are the
libertarians I think just say I'm very
wary of government is hard right yeah I
don't think the system can be perfect so
let's just keep it out of our lives I
mean I think you know which which idea
I'm sympathetic to but do you think
there's a reason that well I think our
is that yes I okay so there are there
are a set of ideas about where do where
do so so the content of political
beliefs like whether for example you
believe in whatever it is pick it I know
any the the the the belief you have
about a particular topic because of
course not evolutionarily shaped but
there is a kind of evolutionary shaping
to whether or not you are more
conservative or liberal right so that's
yeah so some people are more
rule-abiding and there's an there's a
good for example children that learn
children that listen to their parents
might be more likely to survive so
listening to your parents is actually a
good survival strategy on the other hand
too much obedience is also bad you can
be led like a lemming off a cliff so
occasionally you need to not listen to
what everyone else is doing so both are
advantageous and we're we're equipped
with both
abilities and there's variation across
people and it's a complicated topic so
nobody thinks there's like a genetic
background to being a Democrat or a
Republican but right there is evidence
that there is a kind of genetic
predisposition to certain political
polls but what I would say though is
that we live in a plural democracy so
you're gonna have to compromise you know
if your libertarian who thinks XY and Z
and you're gonna be in a society with
other people who think different things
we have decided to come together as a
people and vote to resolve our disputes
and to by the way not just vote but to
educate ourselves and to teach each
other stuff right to communicate right
the founders recognized that in order
for us to get to the wisest decision we
attempt free and open conversation well
I think that's why which I said what I
do here of cool well of course you do
but that's why so many people are so
concerned about this at the college
layer you know I'll hear some of our
critics will say oh they're just
obsessed with what's happening on
colleges and they're handing over all
this power to the to the mob on colleges
but then but then every day we see it
then leaked out and also these people
will be the leaders of tomorrow that's
why I don't think it's I don't think
it's overestimating it even if it is a
small minority which we agree the amount
of power they can extend they definitely
needs to be way disproportionate to the
numbers for sure I would agree with that
I would agree that the vast majority of
students on any college campus just want
to get a good education and and many of
them have other political concerns other
than some of the ones that are getting a
lot of attention so you know even for
example even with a you know so you know
people are concerned about the opioid
crisis they're concerned about gun
violence or concerned about police
brutality they're concerned about the
climate chains are concerned about all
of these issues which I think weren't
concerned we can perfect our society we
can be better than we are and I
generally we can perfect it I do better
than we are you think we can perfect it
no I don't think we can have a perfect
society but I think we can make it
better than it is
so my perfect I mean improve so I think
we can make our society better and
better I don't think we're done yet I
think there's still deficits or for
example our spending is crazy I mean I
think we do better physical fiscally you
know I think we we have we have a car
serial state we have I think I think
this numbers right that are on a per
capita basis we have as many people in
prisons as Stalinist Russia I mean it's
insane you know we we have millions of
Americans are in prison and it's way out
of proportion to other countries you
know there are lots of things about our
society we have very high we have
century-long heights of income
inequality in our society there's a big
debate about whether that is an
unavoidable
side effect of growth you know everyone
is better off so what do we care if the
income is unequally distributed but I
think I tend to be agree with the
critics that are concerned that this
level of inequality is not sustainable
to have a common wheel to like have a
sense that everyone is a part of the
society we've had no income growth in
the middle like the median American has
seen in a generation has seen no growth
in wages right so the bottom actually
has raised and we watched the top go
bananas but the middle baby no the
bottom hasn't even gone up that much
either well let me put this way they
have absolutely no up in living
standards right right so like a poor
America today is vastly better off than
a poor American a generation ago but in
terms of wage growth there's been very
little growth my understanding of
statistics and most of the accumulation
and wealth in the last generation has
gone to the top top 1% Thom 0.1% anyway
there's a debate about why that happened
a technological advance do we have the
same thing during the Industrial
Revolution these are important deep
ideas which is a society we should be
debating and be discussing what's the
best for our society anyway there these
are all much more important topics in my
view and have much more bearing on the
well-being of our society than a lot of
the other crap that gets so much
attention so what's the evolutionary
reason for that I mean your previous
book well that was about social media
right nobody so there's got to be some
link there I mean and I get back to what
I was saying about depressing local news
I don't know I mean I'm trying to talk
about things that I think are important
you know I I'm doing my part as best I
can
who's done a society in a more
quote-unquote good way so I so the book
so I don't I don't I'm not it's not a
work of history so I'm not I'm not I
don't primarily talk about like the last
200 or even 2,000 years of human
evolution or experience I'm much more
interested in the long arc of our
history and if you look at forager
societies around the world as I do and
you and you look at their qualities you
will see that again and again these
societies have these desirable
properties they there's very ancient of
course and how cooperative they are and
there's variation and marital systems
and there's variation in in sustenance
systems there's a lot of variation but
also there's a lot of
commonality and and those common
features I argue are Universal see
here's the other argument so the
argument is that there are these
universal qualities that are shared
across all societies they are shaped by
our evolution they're not just a product
of historical forces can you just list
out a couple of them so so loves from
what so love Friendship Cooperation
we're cooperative species you'll be kind
to a stranger and the first you know
teaching the fact that we teach each
other stuff which actually is the
ultimate source of all our wealth and
well-being the fact that we can
accumulate knowledge and distribute it
across time and place so I can tell
people far away something and when I'm
born I benefit from all the other
knowledge that has been produced for the
minute did hundreds of thousands of
years before me
it's a spawning and I would again argue
this is why what's happening on ecology
yes such a concern I would argue with I
would agree with that there's a
connection there like our capacity to
teach and to create environments in
which we foster teaching and learning
are crucial anyway also mild hierarchy
we are species that we cannot survive
with no hierarchy mmm-hmm we need some
leaders and I discuss that but we also
don't like too much hierarchy so when
you get to autocratic of power the low
guys down below band together and
basically kill so Richard Wrangham has
been making this argument that we self
domesticated as a species that over
millennia bands of weaker members would
say you know that guy's too powerful and
he's getting all the dates and this
we're gonna kill him and basically they
did so we got more peaceful as time went
by as one of the ideas mild hierarchy
in-group bias so some tribalism is
unavoidable in human beings this
capacity for identity that we discussed
at the beginning these are all qualities
so identity love friendship social
networks mild hierarchy in-group bias
teaching and social learning these are
seen everywhere and they lie and I
believe at the core of a good society
and and institutions try to suppress
those at their own peril yeah
how can you we sort of have a healthy
dose of in-group preference without
starting to fall into the trap of
identity politics so for example your
Greek guys yes I've been in a Greek fat
kid I love Greek is my best child friend
in the Greek we're still great friends I
love Greek culture and the way you could
open a Greek and the interest in in
intellectualism and I love feta cheese
and all of those things spanakopita yes
yes great so what and you could open a
Greek restaurant as far as I'm concerned
I wouldn't object
that poor that poor girl it's insane
yeah Oh Chinese without being Chinese
and his coming not just that there was
that there's the person in in in Oregon
that a head out of that max yes so many
examples it is unbelievable so how can
you say love okay I just told you all
the reasons that is your but let's
pretend
yes let's say it's roughly the same feel
about your own culture how can you
embrace all of those things without
falling into the trap of identity
politics because I think that yeah so I
think what a lot of people are at these
days okay so I have a couple of ideas in
response to the first thing I would say
is is that that this is one of the both
the most it's still not totally clear
how we evolved to have this capacity
it's felt that this in-group bias this
this tribalism that we have was crucial
to our ability to cooperate that the
ability to draw a distinction between us
and them that the challenge the problem
that that this ability that we evolved
so so there's whether we cooperate with
each other and whether we are xenophobic
or tribalistic or draw distinctions
between us and them and this property
this tribalism property is a property
that reduces the scale of interactions
so instead of you having to cooperate
with everybody you only cooperate with
your guys and this is innate in human
beings and it is felt that this ability
to draw a distinction between us and
then was crucial in the emergence of the
very ability to cooperate within other
people okay so they're tied they're
connected to each other what's
depressing is is it necessary to hate
the other group why can't you just love
your own group right so why could you be
indifferent to the other group or even
admire and say that's them they're not
us we like them or we're different to
that right why do we have to kill them
right like why you know where does the
killing part come from and this is
complicated we don't exactly know like
where the hostility comes in whether but
we tend to see this hostility so for
example they're famous experiments that
have been done with little toddlers you
can randomly assign toddler
two different t-shirts you can test that
the toddlers understand that this was
random that there was no merit to
whether they got the yellow t-shirt or
the green t-shirt and yet as soon as you
give them the t-shirts the yellow
t-shirt kids say those green t-shirt
children they shouldn't have toys
they're bad children they don't deserve
you know anything it's insane
look at like you can sue this called the
minimal group experiments so with the
most trivial of interventions you can
illicit in us this this this dislike of
the other however this is not the only
tool that evolution has given us to live
together this this ability to draw the
boundary between us in them there are a
couple of other tools and before I tell
you what those two other tools are let
me just say one other thing so if you
think of our societies here's our whole
society and here's our groups in the
middle and here individuals at the
bottom if you're struggling with the
problem of tribalism they're basically
two ways you can go you can go up a
level and broaden the boundary and you
can say for example we are all Americans
mm-hmm right you can say because we all
have the capacity to draw the boundary
we are evolved to have that capacity now
you just say actually these little group
boundaries that we were paying attention
to they're not they're not relevant and
so basically take all the ethnic
divisions or religious or immigrants or
whatever it is they we're all American
we're all Americans other group yes I at
a higher level exactly so you move up a
level and you if face tribalism by
appeal to larger groups this has been
part of our history since the beginning
to talk Ville talks about this we're a
nature of joiners you know and anyone
can be an American that itself is part
of the American project it's astonishing
the belief which I share that anyone can
be an American is a statement that the
group's don't matter anyone can be an
American you just have to buy our
liberal principles and then there's also
an interesting parable to Trump here
because at some level it's like he's
talking about America all the time so
that is the higher group for all yes
and yet I suspect your feelings on what
he's doing yes Rachel there's some other
things probably not so no but I would be
late anyone could be an American if you
come to our country and you work and are
productive and and obey our laws and our
Constitution you're an American
unconcern didn't matter whether you came
from Mexico or you know one of the four
Mexican countries is he's you know
anyway okay so a whole other show okay
so so okay so so but another solution
okay if to the group is of the tribalism
is to go down a level remember we talked
earlier about individuals so now you can
say instead of looking at people as
which groups are they a member of you
look at them as individual people and
this to has been a part of our history
so Martin Luther King's famous sentiment
I you know I'd look forward to a society
in which people are judged by the
content of their character rather than
the color of their skin is it appeal to
our individuality
I think groups don't matter individuals
matter so so if we're struggling with
tribalism we go up or we can go down
both help
however lateral to that point there's
another set of ideas which is tribalism
is not even the only tool we have in
order to reduce the sense of scale and
to cooperate so natural selection has
also equipped us with friendship
friendship the real one of the reasons
it is felt we evolved the capacity for
friendship is again to reduce the sense
of scale so instead of now on being in a
big group everyone has to cooperate with
everyone each of us has a subset of
people who are our friends that we
cooperate with so it's similar to
tribalism but different because now
instead of defining it by a group
membership is defined by each person has
their particular friends so this is
another tool that we innately have that
we can use to sustain our cooperative
instincts and push aside the tribalism
so how much do you think on a day-to-day
they and a day-to-day basis are we
normally I get the water for people you
have to be so wrapped up there that's
what I forgot on a day-to-day basis how
much movement do we as individuals have
to sort of either go around let's say go
around our evolutionary behavior well I
don't think okay so I think I do believe
in free will I mean I think you have
some capacity to self mastery and make
your own decisions in life and your own
you know but you're also born with
certain innate qualities and you're also
born a human being which is you're part
of a particular species that has a
particular
of characteristics so I I think that as
individuals you know we we have some
control over how we act I don't think
our individual actions will individually
change the whole society but I think if
each of us is attempting to do the right
thing I think ultimately that makes
things better look there's a lot of
famous ideas so a Viktor Frankl who was
in the concentration camps his wife was
killed he survives the Nazi
concentration camps and he goes and he
writes a famous book called man's search
for meaning after he's liberated it
writes it ten days after his liberation
and he talks about how he came to the
recognition that even in this camp in
the most vile possible circumstance
where his life was threatened every day
where people were dying all the time he
was starving to death he had no shoes it
was in the winter I mean it was a slave
even there he recognized that he was the
master of his own internal state you
know that how he saw the world was
something that was in his own control so
he was able to find a sense of
self-discipline and mastery even in an
environment in which the structures
around him were engineered to crush him
to kill him so so I think that there and
there many examples of this I mean
another one of my favorite examples is
Buddhist monks that were studied at MIT
years ago I think I'm gonna get the
facts of this war correct so so so they
were very interested in how meditation
changes the structure of your brain and
how are these monks so able to be so
peaceful in these very stressful
circumstances and they scan them they
put them in the MRI scanner and they
looked at different parts of their brain
and which parts were enhanced or
diminished compared to other more
ordinary mortals and and then and and
they saw that different parts of the
brain and Buddhist monks were different
than the rest of us but what interested
me was not even the neuroanatomical
discoveries that were in that paper but
it was the interviews with the monks and
so what the monks would say was that for
example let's say you and I are in
traffic and someone cuts us off a normal
response certainly one that I often have
is man who is that jerk you know gonna
be really pissed off and your blood
pressure would rise and maybe he would
race that
and you know you would you would think
you love them that would be your natural
go-to thing that's a thoughtless maybe
their idiotic or their inattentive or
you would have all these bad thoughts
about this person who you know in a road
rage kind of way the monks don't do that
but the monks do is is they train
themselves to rina rate so when that
happens to them they say maybe that's a
man who's taking his wife to the
hospital because she's delivering the
baby the baby's being born in the car in
front of me is that amazing there's a
new life I should help that man to get
to the hop I mean and they're doing it
not for the sake of that person but for
their own well-being you see so so I
think it's possible to to to do even
though it's difficult it is very
difficult to exercise some internal
self-control I think you're mostly
saying that there are no monks on
Twitter
yes very few the Dalai Lama I think is
on Twitter I think I think I have to
check yeah he's on Facebook I'm pretty
sure what else do you think sort of the
average person that's watching this can
do to help order a good society because
I think people you know everything's
become so political yes he said I think
people think that's the only solution to
sort of help make a better I think
granting charity to your enemies I think
is important I think listening to them
cultivating listening you know that's
pretty big of you to say after
everything that you well I was listening
in the clip you shot I was listening I
thought that was a ridiculous that the
young woman who said I'm not listening
to her I was really listening I mean I
was listening then and before and after
I don't agree with what she was saying
but I heard what she said I could
summarize what she was saying but even
but what do you do in that case then it
just sort of you know we don't to bring
it back to the Pacific insets but in
generals because I think a lot of people
are going through this you're being
berated by somebody they're saying all
the worst things about you yes shooting
your motives yes they're attacking you
as a person all of those things now you
can listen you can absorb you can ignore
you can ignore which is also good Ruth
Bader Ginsburg says the survival in life
is ignoring a lot of the stupidities
which I also think is good I think
that's the answer and what was it ignore
and also who was that famous actress
that found this guy in Texas that had
said horrible things to her and then or
him my cameraman was an actor and
actress and it was an
Chris and made it her business to find
out about this guy's life and he had
lost his health insurance and he and
then she intervened and raised money for
his health care and and and he felt seen
and heard wow I can't it's an incredible
story and and I think that a lot of
times people and I think anonymity is a
real it can contribute to bad behavior
online so I think sort of as jordan
peterson says you know man up as it were
a woman up and have the strength of your
convictions this is what i think this is
what I'm gonna say but is there a
problem I mean Jordan I've done this
many times where then depending on how
that hierarchical structure is operated
if you are saying something that's
unpolitical II yes correct well I mean
you have to have the strength rule or
revise your opinions or stick to them or
make good arguments but but you know you
don't engage let's say you're a trump
supporter you just don't want to lose
your job because you think if you say
that I'm against people losing their
jobs for their opinions yeah so so you
know so I think that I think there's a
thing where I think a little bit of
bravery a little bit of civil discourse
a little bit of commitment to granting
charity to our opponents a little bit of
like for example when I would have an
argument with people who are opposed to
vaccinations I think there is no merit
to their ideas I understand they're
fierce I understand that there have been
either some actual cases of vaccine
induced neurological conditions one in a
hundred thousand one in five hundred
thousand cases which is awful and I
understand that there are a lot of
coincidences where people think that
there's a relationship but no it's just
that you have you know you have a lot of
vaccines are being administered there
are a lot of illnesses occuring there's
gonna be an overlap in those two sets
and I also know the date on how that's
very bent at how vaccination is like a
twenty twentieth and twenty it's
actually more like even a 19th century
triumph I mean you know we've we've
mastered these diseases we humans it's
astonishing what we've done through our
capacity to teach and learn and engage
in science and so forth but I would
engage that person I would try to I
would talk to them I would say you know
let me talk to you about your beliefs
and because I think that that's the only
way to get them to revise their beliefs
I think telling them they're fools
doesn't doesn't help true liberal I am a
liberal yes I am I am I am a liberal
yeah but do you think one side is
a little it's a little bit easier to do
that right now and does that flip over
time so for example right now I find it
much easier yes to go to concert I get
invited by an observant of cliffs
libertarians it's no problem but that's
fake conservatives that I have
disagreements on on abortion yes gain in
origin legalizing marijuana and the
death penalty and we could do the list
wait hold on so I'm for legalization
marijuana yes what is your position on
death penalty I'm against death me too
gay marriage yes yeah legalizing weed
yes
so I yes so I hate to tell you I'm
guessing that you only would get invited
by conservative groups to basically to
college well I don't know I don't know I
don't get that many I mean usually my
invitations are scientific like I'm a
scientist like I give talks about my
science so I I have not historically
been very politically but right so but
what I'm getting at really is that at
the moment it seems very obvious to me
like I don't know that I could be clear
or anything that is on the center-right
there's there's a an ability and
actually a desire to discuss ideas I
would greet a disagree and that just
isn't happening right well I was right
now and I would suspect or argue and I'm
sure you give me examples where that yes
I mean during McCarthyism for example I
think you know it's very difficult to be
the communist for sure and even you know
left-wing fifties so they weren't
inviting communist yes that's right
that's right and so I think I honestly
don't know the answer to that question I
think there are subgroups on campus
which are still committed to debate they
get the political unions these guys love
to argue these young people I think
there are other vocal minorities on
campus that don't want to hear opinions
that they don't agree with and they
think that even the hearing of it
there's this there's this very sloppy
conflation of speech with violence which
i think is ridiculous
which seems to really be ramping up yes
I would agree with that and you also see
it burn instance in Pakistan they will
they will kill apostates well that's
answering speech with violence if you
actually think that someone believing in
a different God and expressing that
belief is violence then then that
country justifies killing that person or
in Brunei recently they had the same
kind of situation I think this this is I
I strongly reject that belief there's
there's a we have different words and
there's a totally different meaning
between speech and violence
so so I don't know how we got onto that
topic but oh so so I think that I think
there are my groups of people on campus
who do conflate speech and violence I
think that's a problem but there are
also many groups that are very very
vigorous political debates I think one
thing that is different so I'm in my 50s
when I was in college in my in the 80s
we would stay up late and argue about
politics with our friends with our
friends notice I said yeah my friend
yeah I wouldn't argue with my friends
about politics and and they were my
friends I don't think that happens very
much anymore it does in the political
unions in the debate societies but in
the broader College I think if you have
a different opinion about abortion for
example you really can't express that
but the weird thing is that it is
happening with conservatives well
because they do believe I mean I go to
these things and I have these debates
yes overall and they're better debaters
because they have more experience yes
arguing with people they disagree with
yeah yes they get a better education in
some ways because they have to
constantly defend their opinions it's a
weird thing being that's all happy to
say that yes yes yes I think I mean if
you this is the thing why in the martial
arts for example why do we bow to our
opponent you learn more from the people
you disagree with and from the people
you agree with right and jeaious Mills
famous saying you know he who knows only
his side of the case knows little of it
so you know I think I think that's where
your ideas get better when they are
tested when you argue with someone you
disagree with and and and I think and I
think cultivating those kinds of
conversations disciplining yourself to
be able to have arguments with people
you disagree with improves your ideas
and actually you should be grateful to
that person there's more interesting
person in some ways now you don't have
to be best friends with that person
necessarily although you can be but I
think it makes you smarter that my
friend is a nice closing statement and
you've lived through it I mean that's
the knowing you you lived through the
forces that so many of us see now is as
such dangerous forces in society and now
that you lived through it you flourished
and you've got another book out and all
of those things well I would say
I mean yeah well I would close with
saying you know I really believe that
that the arc of our evolution is long
but it bends towards goodness sounds
good to me
you guys could follow Nick on Twitter at
na Christakis and we'll have a link to
his book right down below
[Music]